the public is so politicized that if I
were in a moderating a presidential
debate and I were to say that to one of
the candidates you know you're really
off point and you're not responding
everybody would think that that means
i'm on the other guys side and that
doesn't happen in the intelligence
squared debates I I don't know why but
the audience the audience recognizes and
understands that what I'm trying to do
is to protect the integrity of the
debate that if I'm that if I'm calling
somebody for not to really debating well
that our audience gets it then my what
I'm trying to do is to make the debate
better not help one side or the other I
think in the presidential debates the
moderators if they don't interrupt it's
their fault for letting the debate run
off the rails and if they do interrupt
they get attacked for taking sides and
that's why I just I think it's a sort of
know it's a very difficult situation I
actually thinking we have proposed to
the presidential debate Commission that
they do the debates our way have a
stated motion do an oxford style debate
at least one time I would be happy to
moderate it you're you're going to
really do a debate you're going to
debate about for and against this motion
you're going to be okay with me
interrupting it won't you won't take it
as an insult you won't take it as me
taking sides and and may the best person
win